¿Cómo se puede medir eso?
¿Cómo pudimos medir eso?
Hace unos cincuenta años,
había unos físicos visionarios en Caltech y MIT,
Kip Thorne, Ron Drever, Rai Weiss,
que pensaban que se podían medir precisamente distancias
usando láseres que midieran distancias entre espejos
que estaban a kilómetros de distancia.
Tomó muchos años y mucho trabajo y muchos científicos
desarrollar la tecnología, desarrollar las ideas,
y 20 años después,
hace casi 30 años, más de 20,
se empezaron a construir dos detectores de ondas gravitacionales,
dos interferómetros,
en los Estados Unidos,
cada uno con cuatro kilómetros de largo.
Uno [está] en el estado de Louisiana,
en Livingston, Louisiana, en medio de un bosque precioso;
el otro, en Hanford, Washington,
el estado de Washington, en medio del desierto.
En estos interferómetros, tenemos láseres que viajan desde el centro,
cuatro kilómetros en vacío,
se reflejan en espejos y vuelven,
y estamos midiendo la diferencia de distancia
entre este brazo y este brazo.
Y estos detectores son muy muy muy sensibles,
son los instrumentos más precisos del mundo.
¿Por qué hicimos dos?
Porque las señales que queremos medir vienen del espacio
son las que queremos medir,
pero los espejos se están moviendo todo el tiempo,
entonces para distinguir efectos ondas gravitacionales,
que son efectos astrofísicos y deben aparecer en los dos detectores,
podemos distinguirlos de los efectos locales,
que aparecen distintos, en uno o en el otro.
En septiembre del 2015,
estábamos terminando de instalar la segunda generación de tecnología
en estos detectores,
y todavía no estábamos a la sensibilidad óptima que queremos --
todavía no estamos allí,
incluso dos años después,
pero ya queríamos tomar datos.
No pensábamos que íbamos a ver nada,
pero estábamos preparando para empezar a tomar datos por unos meses.
Y la naturaleza nos sorprendió.
El 14 de septiembre del 2015,
vimos en los dos detectores
una onda gravitacional.
En los dos detectores vimos una señal
con unos ciclos que crecían en amplitud de frecuencia
después decaían,
y eran los mismos en los dos detectores.
Eran ondas gravitacionales.
Y no solo eso, sino que, descodificando esta forma de onda,
podíamos deducir que venían de agujeros negros
fusionándose en uno solo,
hace más de mil millones de años.
Y esto fue --
(Aplausos)
Esto fue fantástico.
Al principio, no lo podíamos creer.
Esto no se suponía que tenía que pasar
hasta más adelante.
Fue una sorpresa para todos.
Nos tomó meses convencernos de que esto era cierto,
porque no queríamos dar lugar a ningún error.
Pero era cierto,
y para despejar toda duda
de que realmente los detectores podían medir estas cosas,
en diciembre del mismo año, medimos otra onda gravitacional
más chiquita que la primera.
La primera onda gravitacional produjo una diferencia de distancia
de cuatro milésimas de protón.
sobre cuatro kilómetros.
Sí, la segunda detección fue más chica
pero todavía muy convincente para nuestros estándares
A pesar de que estas son ondas de espacio-tiempo,
no ondas de sonido,
a nosotros nos gusta ponerlas en parlantes y escucharlas.
Le decimos a esto "la música del universo".
Aquí les quiero hacer escuchar las primeras dos notas
de esta música.
(Silbido)
La segunda, la más cortita fue la última fracción de segundo
de estos dos agujeros negros,
que en esa fracción de segundo emitieron un montón de energía --
tanta energía -- como la de tres soles convirtiéndose en energía
siguiendo esa fórmula famosa,
E = mc2.
¿Se acuerdan?
Esta música, en realidad, a nosotros nos encanta tanto,
bailamos con esto,
que se la voy a hacer escuchar de nuevo.
(Silbido)
¡Es la música del universo!
(Aplausos)
Frecuentemente la gente me pregunta ahora:
¿Para qué sirven las ondas gravitacionales?
Y ahora que ya las descubrieron,
¿qué queda por hacer?
¿Para qué sirven las ondas gravitacionales?
Cuando a Borges le preguntaron:
"¿Para qué sirve la poesía?"
Él a su vez preguntó:
"¿Para qué sirve el amanecer?
¿Para qué sirven las caricias?
¿Para qué sirve el olor a café?"
Y él se respondió:
"La poesía sirve para el placer, para la emoción, para vivir".
Y entender el universo,
esta curiosidad humana por saber cómo funciona todo
es parecido.
La humanidad, desde tiempo inmemorial,
y todos nosotros, todos ustedes de chicos,
cuando se mira el cielo por primera vez
y se ven estrellas, uno se pregunta:
"¿Qué son las estrellas?"
Esa curiosidad es lo que nos hace humanos.
Y eso es lo que hacemos con la ciencia.
A nosotros nos gusta decir
que las ondas gravitacionales ya están sirviendo,
porque estamos abriendo una nueva manera de explorar el universo.
Hasta ahora, pudimos ver la luz de las estrellas
a través de las ondas electromagnéticas.
Ahora podemos escuchar el sonido del universo
aun de cosas que no emiten luz, como ondas gravitacionales.
(Aplausos)
(Inglés) Gracias.
Pero ¿solo para eso servirán?
¿No se deriva ninguna tecnología de ondas gravitacionales?
A lo mejor, sí.
Pero va probablemente a tomar mucho tiempo.
Hemos desarrollado tecnología para detectarlas,
pero las ondas mismas, a lo mejor se descubra de acá a cien años
que sirven para algo.
Pero toma mucho tiempo derivar tecnología de la ciencia
y no es por eso que lo hacemos.
Toda tecnología se deriva de la ciencia,
pero la ciencia la hacemos
para el placer.
¿Qué nos queda por hacer?
Muchísimo.
Muchísimo. Esto es recién el comienzo.
A medida que hacemos los detectores más sensibles --
y nos queda bastante por hacer --
no solo vamos a ver más agujeros negros,
vamos a poder hacer un catálogo para saber cuántos hay, dónde están
cuán grandes son,
sino que también, vamos a ver otros objetos.
Vamos a ver la fusión de estrellas de neutrones,
que se convierten en un agujero negro.
Vamos a ver nacer a un agujero negro.
Vamos a poder ver estrellas rotantes en nuestra galaxia
produciendo ondas sinusoidales.
Vamos a poder ver explosiones de supernovas en nuestra galaxia.
Es todo un espectro de nuevas fuentes que vamos a estar viendo.
Nos gusta decir
que hemos agregado un nuevo sentido al cuerpo humano:
ahora, además de ver,
podemos escuchar.
Esto es una revolución en la astronomía,
así como cuando Galileo inventó el telescopio,
o como cuando al cine mudo se le agregó el sonido.
Esto es apenas el comienzo.
Nos gusta pensar
que el camino de la ciencia es muy largo --
muy divertido, pero muy largo --
y esta gran comunidad internacional de científicos trabajando en equipo
desde muchos países, todos juntos,
estamos ayudando a construir este camino,
poniendo luces,
a veces encontrando desvíos,
y construyendo, a lo mejor,
una autopista al universo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)